and
i was in a hammock asleep after lunch
and i was under a tree and i just heard
a terrible roar and i
woke up rolled out of that hammock and i
looked up into the ass end of two
military jets going straight up with
afterburners glowing
then they turned around just like they
would on an air show and they come up
the airstrip
and just tore it up with 50 caliber
bullets and i said whoa whoa whoa
and i jumped out of that and i ran for
the airplane and i just gave the guy 80
thousand dollars and he took off in the
truck the other way i should have went
with him
but i was thinking about getting out of
here so i got in the plane and
i uh i took off and co-pilot got in with
me
and uh the two fellas and we had about
10 or 12
barrels of gasoline in the in the
back in the baggage area or where the
seats used to be
in the cabin and the 55-gallon drums of
aviation fuel so i took off
and the two jets got right beside me and
the pilots were so close almost like
you and i just and they kept telling me
to go to via vincenzia military base
were they telling how are they telling
you on the radio or no they was pointing
towards you they did that no idea you
could see them not close
oh yeah we were just they were they had
their wingtips over my wingtips
they want me to go to the military base
they're pointing at it
and i just put up the old hippie sign no
one shook my hand at them
i didn't think they would shoot me so
they just kept swarming on me and i kept
slowing that dc3 down until they were
just standing on their tails burning all
kinds of fuel
black smoke coming out of their tails
those planes aren't meant to go that
slow no
so anyhow they kind of went under me and
started shooting them
20 millimeter cannons boom boom boom
boom boom
just shake the airplane so i pushed the
nose over so they couldn't get under me
i'd fly a treetop level
and later on they said that i tried to
crash into one of them but i really
didn't and i didn't know it
so uh later on they come and they they
uh shot holes in the tail with 50
caliber just with a sweet
zip let me just put a few and uh oh boy
that got my attention and then they then
they shot up the left wingtip
and i said oh my and there was a there
was a one of them left i guess for fuel
so there was a
black rolling clouds ahead well wait
first off
i understand first off i couldn't get my
wheels up i didn't take
on a dc3 they have uh pins
that you stick in the struts so that if
the hydraulic collapses
the plane won't go down all the way on
the ground okay so it's just like a
strut goes up down
and i'd left those pins in i got
insagosa fast
oh so i uh it was a big pasture up ahead
so i landed
and it was rougher than it looked and
the and the
fuel caps popped off all over the place
and so on the world series baseball game
it interrupted this baseball game to
tell you as american dc-3 has just been
shot down by colombian jets
this is the first plane that's been shot
down on a reagan new war on drugs
and then uh then in a minute it says up
he's up up and away
we'll keep you posted i took off again
this was in the middle of the world
series that you were getting
chased by these colombian fighter jets
yes we have copies of that
transmission yeah there's actually like
a recording of it
yes during the world series wow
so uh that would be a cool thing to find
if you can i would i think i got
my friend jerry's got a copy of that
really yeah okay
so uh we um
went on and i went into these took off
and i went into these boiling clouds and
the clouds stick close to the mountains
in the tropics and those mountains go up
20 000 feet there in
that part of columbia in the andes and i
was afraid to go in much further so i
i went on up to about twenty thousand
feet and i started getting some ice
so i came back out again and there was
that jet right there boom boom
got your plane that's it wow
was it all metal like that too also like
shiny metal like uh
one of those uh those air stream bands
yes that one was but they um that one i
think it's beautiful
was a blue and white one so uh
um where was i
oh yeah so i mean boom boom boom he's
shooting at me again the pins the pins
are in the struts you forgot
i already got the ammo popped off again
with no new fuel caps on top
oh oh you let you crash landed no i just
landed on a pasture
just straight of just a big cow pasture
okay those things got huge tires as big
as a semi truck so okay and stuff like
that
okay that was rough i mean it was up and
down and i got out and took those pins
out and took off again
holy [ __ ] so but i was afraid that he
was going to hit one of them tracer
shoot through the fuselage and
right you've got fuel or hit the gas
tanks i'd just go up in a ball of flames
so yeah i was i was serious about it so
when i went back in i thought okay i
can't get away in the place
plane was icing up real bad at that
altitude so i just kicked it over into a
stall into a spin spin right down to
about
2000 feet and i just came out under it
it was just beautiful down on there so
okay explain that again for people who
aren't familiar with uh with
flying in aviation so you took off again
from the cow pasture yes and you flew up
to how hot 20
000 feet 20 000 i suppose about that and
that plane wasn't made to fly that high
would go that high but you need oxygen
yeah but you can stand
you're not supposed to go fifteen
thousand feet without oxygen but you can
stand for a while without it for sure
you can
right you lose your um you get fuzzy
okay and so what was the reason that you
you purposely stalled the airplane
vertically oh to get away from that
to get away from the jet i was gonna
leave him up there so i just stalled it
and when you stall one you you put it up
into a stall and put
it fall over in one wing and then it's
like a falling leaf it'll just spiral
and it'll spiral in it's just almost go
down as fast as you if if you dropped it
i mean it really goes fast it's like
it's falling on one wing
is this something that you had done
before like i mean this seems like a
crazy maneuver to try
no people don't do that so you learn
this when you're yeah i think a lot of
people aren't
just being and and the reason that you
stalled the airplane was to get
off of his radar or just to get away
from him just do something maneuver real
quick
just so like i don't know where you
stopped and then drop and then he would
lose you
well i didn't know that he would but he
did right so i got away from him and
now i feel bulletproof all right your
adrenaline's pumping
i'm gonna go get that load of marijuana
three tons waiting on us down there but
we can't go back to the gorillas
because they don't run us off right we
gotta wait till about dark to get there
right
so i'm uh flying along the guaviri river
it's way on down in columbia closer to
brazil
and it's on the same flight yeah this is
right after that's where i'm supposed to
go to start with
okay we're waiting at that other farm
right until we could go
in the evening to the gorillas right
so i see a long grassy strip it looks
like it's 20 feet above the river
and i said i got to find a spot we won't
have enough fuel to fly all afternoon
and then
and then fly home
[Music]
and so on this grass i guess it was
about waist deep and i just i just
touched the wheels down lightly and i
made a half a mile
strip and the wheels are 18 inches wide
i guess
the first rate it looked good in the
second row it looked bigger and the
third row and i went four or five times
and
put a little more weight on the tires
each time and it was hard as a rock
and so i told you so you kept circling
and going down and touching down
and going to make you're making your own
runway right
wow so i did it and uh where did you did
you learn how to do this
is this something that you learned like
you know but on the farm and a tractor
you do all kinds of stuff to get there
didn't
you know it would look like it was
smooth but what i didn't know
and so i had the co-pilot's name al and
so when was almost coming to a stop i
said get your feet off that brakes out
i don't have my feet on the brakes and
what has happened was that thing weighs
30 tons
and on those two tires they were
breaking through the crust it was like
oh i guess about eight inch it's deep of
real hard clay like
and beneath beneath that was soup where
the water had stayed
so the wheels went through and it just
started slowly doing a handstand until
it went right straight up
and the nose and all just came in slowly
on us and we fell in between the seats
to save our lives because it was
collapsing on you the nose was just in
the plane was coming up on his tail just
like this [ __ ] just like that
and it stopped right straight up and
down 90 degrees you couldn't have put a
a ruler on it and the two big engines
you see those big engines they held it
up yeah and uh
so i just undid the uh emergency
uh hatch and stepped down in the grass
and owl came behind me and we reached in
and got our suitcases now the two guys
back up in the
in the fuselage they got kind of banged
up with all them drum cases
and it's 100 feet not 100 feet but it's
high up there to that door
i mean high so they tie a couple of fuel
hoses and they shimmy down
and we set out walking unbelievable man
and that was uh that's when i they went
down the road
and i went through the jungle so you're
in the middle of nowhere in colombia
yeah and i said listen i'll eat snakes
in this jungle for
a year before i go down the road after
the jets had done what they did and what
we did and so i went through the jungle
and after 11 days i came to a place i
kept asking the indians done this
diabetes
where are airplanes loma linda loma
linda where is it leos
is far and i kept going where are
airplanes
where where can i find an airplane okay
in the spanish donde esta avions
avionis so i'd speak into the indians
and
i eat brown sugar and drink the water
and i had a
uh st paul bag from the cleaner plastic
and i'd put the brown and bought a block
of brown sugar and i'd put that water in
it and
i get along pretty good on that huh uh
just brown sugar and water and brown
sugar and water for some days when i
have anything to eat so i uh
finally i came to a place and uh
wow what is this place like hawaii world
war
ii green roofs a pasture a nice long
runway several airplanes a tower
and i knocked on the door i said what is
this place what how did you kids hear my
name
katie sue did a lovely voice he said
i'm touring [ __ ] we don't get tourists
here
so uh what is this place you don't
know this is loma linda headquarters for
missionary
missionary aviation fellowship for the
amazon
so god just tapped me on the shoulder
the same people that had learned to fly
these are the people that went to their
place
and one and one of their pilots with an
old missionary from canada
flew me out the next morning and we flew
to the same military base where they
tried to get me to go
and the policeman reached in and got my
bag out of the out of the airplane and
put it in a taxi
wow and the other fellows went on to
prison for some years downing
they went to prison oh yeah and i knew
they were going
for sure i knew they were going i said
come with me please
[Laughter]
wow
i